[Musique]
moi je viens d'un petit village au nord
de montréal saint gabriel de brandon et
on avait une maison qui était à l'orée
de la forêt une très grande forêt bahia
j'avais toujours l'impression que cette
forêt là s'étendait jusqu'au bout n'en
ai vraiment développer un attachement
pour la forêt je dirais même que j'ai
besoin d'aller en forêt je vais
régulièrement
il faut absolument conserver la
biodiversité conservée la complexité
d'un réflexe qu'on a perdu on a perdu à
cause de l'agriculture ce qu'on a fait
on a pris une plante quelques plein dans
la culture et on a créé des grandes
monocultures la foresterie cet aspect
est inspiré de l'agriculture pour
développer ces stratégies et à cause de
cela on doit utiliser des herbicides on
doit user dé les engrais on doit faire
beaucoup d'efforts pour maintenir un éco
système productif parce qu'on le
simplifier je fait l'analogie avec le
portefeuille financier les conseils
qu'on reçoit c'est de diversifier le
plus possible notre portefeuille dans
les domaines qui sont les plus
différents possibles pour s'assurer
d'avoir un revenu stable dans le futur
mais en forêt si la même chose puis on
va voir diversité d'organismes on va en
diversité d'espèces plus la forêt vont
être capables de résister à des
perturbations
on va peut-être perdre des espèces ni à
d'autres espèces qui vont prendre la
place et à la fin on veut continuer à
avoir une forêt qui fournit les
fonctions et les services dont l'humain
dépeint les forêts font face à des
menaces importantes des changements
climatiques qui sont d'une rapidité
incroyable mais aussi des espèces
exotiques insectes maladie qui viennent
d'europe d'asie et on a besoin de cette
complexité de cette diversité l'eau et
la forêt ce torride au besoin de se
renouveler et de travailler avec cette
façon